Zoo
200 oh 200.
that's right Dr polis hit a huge
milestone
we are busy he's been helping animals
for half a century that's why you call
us
and we've been catching the magic just
for more than 10 years even at Christmas
20 Seasons I gotta see this and now 200
episodes never done this before
of the Incredible Dr Paul
[Music]
sit back and relax you need makeup for
your head
oh that looks good it's time for a trip
down memory lane I'll be ready come on
let's go
200 episodes Charles did you ever think
that yeah after season one no
yeah it's no better than I did so
there's been 10 years now Diane right I
remember the first year the first four
episodes we did yeah we thought ha we
got done yeah we're done let me go back
to work yep after those first four
episodes I thought okay what what do we
go this is no nobody's gonna watch it
and that's the surprise
when Charles goes out with me it's fun
again when he was a kid he really didn't
want to help but now he doesn't mind
getting his hands dirty you look younger
[Laughter]
at least you don't have a great beard
yet first call is says calf with a lame
foot
hang on right hand Charles is not a vet
but he is the muscle man he's bigger
than I am I'll wrestle it
that's right
I remember seeing this
you're out of practicing
I don't have to do much calf Ringling in
L.A
okay
[Music]
you got something here
I'm sorry he's gonna kick me off I think
there's something he's kick in there
that's a nail
poor guy oh you're flicking it right in
my face first and many times you
freaking maneuvering my face
okay you're done
I haven't done that for years it's fun
having them with me yeah
he makes me laugh again
I'm glad I'm good for something oh yes
I I've learned a lot I've come a long
way with being able to handle animals
that's for sure what I like about is
working together as a family yeah yeah
that was a fun part yes and it's been 10
years and I'm still having fun
[Music]
we were actually one of the first vet
shows it I think paved the way for a
whole new genre of Television actually
that wasn't wasn't around I never
thought that it would be successful like
this but I think that's it's successful
because it's real
when Charles came here with his friends
and said Dad we should make a relatives
about you he said dad do your work
that's interesting enough so when I'm
working with the patients I forget about
the cameras
friction clean me up Charles the cameras
have captured a lot since that first
episode
watch your toes
it shouldn't hurt hey be quiet
in 200 episodes we've seen more than 2
000 cases and we've hand-picked the top
ten
or we get to say our top ten I could I
got I got ten you got ten I got ten I'll
see if you're right
top 10.
[Music]
oh there it is this is it this was one
of my top ones we're headed to Butch
blacks he's got a cabin oh that one yes
oh my gosh and she's been in labor for
four hours so it doesn't sound good
oh shoot
she's the first time ever yep I can tell
Charles chains yeah come on
that was a miserable day
let me have it let me have it man I'm
glad I'm not coming out of this small
hole I didn't know I have all these
comments up yeah I got it
[Music]
I got it yep get it out of there
whoa
Is it alive and the Cap's not breathing
water
and my dad just immediately is like
water water
and my dad just reaches up like come on
come on
that's true I don't know if they showed
that how hard you hit that calf by
getting it debris and down
there he goes maybe a little bit and the
calf started breathing
it was just the most incredible thing
I've ever seen yeah
Charles yeah
but see she's crying that's pretty good
that's damn good
oh that brought tears to my eyes so yeah
that is that you would see with the
farmers yeah they are animals and they
use them on the farm
but when he come out of life they still
cry because they love their animals yep
well we gotta and we got a live
that's why he's the incredible doctor
pull
yeah that was fun I like that one
always just a little bit of this in his
50 years as a vet Dr Paul has perfected
his way of treating animals
let's go
Dr Paul really likes doing the flipping
Stitch flipping Stitch flip and Stitch
we do a flip and Stitch to help put one
of the stomachs of a cow back in place
feel the bump there
the Apple Mason has a stomach that
normally is only filled with water but
if the cow goes our feet it can fill up
with gas and it floats to the top okay
ready
and when you roll the calendar back that
gas pulls the stomach back in place okay
and then we attach the stomach right to
the belly wall
and always leave a head width loose like
that if you put it tight they die don't
ask me why
[Music]
what is the problem she has a hook in
her teeth they said oh
you know how old this horse is
no not truly we just rescued her she's
27 years old
the horse's teeth grow all the time so
when they are born they are nicely
together like this and the older they
get the more the teeth become sticking
out forward
didn't know that huh no
rectal prolapses can happen from
anything that causes straining that can
get from constipation
from parasites I make my own tubes out
of this black PVC pipe put it in there
with a rubber band around it and that
cuts off the whole circulation so this
whole row set of mucosae falls off in
about four or five days the tube falls
out and the pig looks good these look a
lot better you know that
the fastest and cheapest way to tell if
a cow is pregnant is the old-fashioned
way through the rectum
he's done 14 000 pregnancy checks at the
very least you know the first time you
get a glove off people going oh
old school new school again all is about
what can make an animal healthy again
that's the big that's exactly right you
use the newest thing or the oldest thing
if it works
what I feel for this you know the size
of the uterus four months only and the
cavalithens in there and that tells me
how long they are she is five months
it's Easter pregnancy check but step
aside when the tail goes up
I have taught myself to do procedures
that were not taught in school my famous
old bushel basket casket no not casket
my famous bushel basket cast works like
a charm
it's right here it's a bad fracture in
the right rear leg it was a bad fracture
his leg is broken and this is a bad one
did you bring a bushel basket
no gotta find my own
what I like about the Bristol basket is
that it is pliable from side to side but
lengthwise they are very strong
they're not dying tape
so when you incorporate them in a cast
it gives you enough immobility that the
bone really adheres good
and in about three weeks that bone is
healed enough that the calf can walk on
it thanks guys see ya
that Diane I started here 40 years ago
we were 80 Dairy that has changed so
much so that now we are at least 60
percent small animal if it's got four
legs and a heartbeat my dad will see it
whether it's barking mooing oinking or
fishing are you coming out yes
no
cute
over the years doc has seen a veritable
Arc full of species camels are ruminants
like cows but they don't act like cows
that's okay no no you don't like this
they have their own yeah temperament you
could call it
yes that's what I mean
look at all those heads
skinny Ewoks they got the two front
teeth there and the big round eyes and
the Furry heads
hello there how are you oh don't put
your ears back I'll bite you too
let me see if I can oh quit it these
hedgehogs will roll up in a ball so when
you want to look at them you basically
have to try to unroll them a little bit
and have a good look
foreign
[Music]
still
oh my gosh look at those they don't bite
you usually no and I didn't stick my
finger in there because those needle
teeth still would hurt
you never know what comes through the
door but take care of it
that's not something you see every day
in Michigan huh no
I saw him in in Florida and that's
that's enough of them really
I got a call from a young girl who has
an Hindu Brazilian bowl
and I was wondering what
[Music]
there's only about 100 of these in the
United States and my heart just stopped
and I felt absolutely in love with them
Ellen needs a ring Eeyore
this is the first time I've seen this
breed and he is a nice looking creature
you can have a ring or not yes I have
the ring now you see a whole bunch of
them
yeah okay how far in the nose do you
want it
oh I can't watch that
see I don't see the reactions when they
do that I'm working
it didn't even like bleed
okay that looks good
thank you
for me you know a veterans means you're
an animal doctor there are a whole bunch
of different animals and if you don't
know how to treat them somebody has done
it before you
so you look it up and do the best you
can
while the animal stock treats May differ
from day to day
see you later
adios
hi there's one person who has been there
every step of the way it used to be when
we would go to town everybody knew yeah
and everybody would come up with hi doc
now when we go to town any Town yeah I
don't know doctor pole no it's not Diane
right lots of times I'm the first one
recognized and then when they see him
they say oh then they knew for sure that
they were right they recognized me first
Diane has been the one constant at the
clinic through all the years we've got
quite a few calls on the list and we
have surgeries Diane and I have been
building this practice together and I
tell you without her
it would be a shambles
she is a big asset to the practice here
and it's fun working together you're the
heart of the clinic you're pumping
information everywhere you go here you
go there yes
and she's always game to lend a helping
hand
put boots over the shoes I think that's
good enough you look fantastic look
better on Charles
Charles is limping throughout the clinic
with the bridge on his knee so Diane is
going with me that's when the horse
follow me do you want to drive probably
it might be safer
let's go we're late I got a hole in my
pocket
[Music]
Tommy gross here has a racehorse it's a
hot-headed stallion so the thing now to
do is to castrate it shot shut and cut
cut oh I remember this
[Music]
oh
well you got some big ones don't he oh
yeah
[Music]
that's exactly what I was thinking but I
wasn't going to say it
[Laughter]
it's all over now boy
hello Greg hello well this one's been a
strange one she's not been in labor and
she should have had a baby
oh
my camping yeah this is just recently
uterus it's twisted badly too how many
times have you roll that cow Diane oh I
don't know I'm gonna strip first hi
thought we were going to have to give up
on this one
oh yeah
Diane yeah grab a hole
got a pole okay okay
I think we got it hey
it worked this girl's got power
yes the twist came out but the head was
still upside down
after this car has been in labor this
long
come on lady I need that other leg we
have no idea if it's still alive
lubricants I had to go get the
lubricating power or I had to go get the
water is that your first time pulling a
calf yes 30 some years and you have to
wait for a TV show exactly
[Music]
thoughts
okay cool
oh
hold it John was here giving me guidance
as to how much to pull let go let go
when to pull when to stop and all this
kind of stuff he's a lot nicer with you
than he is with me
[Music]
yeah okay
yeah and he's alive yeah
that's well worth it
after we had pulled that calf it just
made the whole day it gave you something
that you felt like you had accomplished
something it keeps you going yeah it
does right yeah right yes that's what it
is yeah what are some of the challenges
of running a family business keeping us
in line
yeah
yeah that is a big challenge
kind of be a boss
is to see Charles and Jan working
together
because when Charles was young he really
didn't want to go out on Farm calls he
was always interested in films and shows
and movies and Jan was always interested
in animals and to see these two work
together I think that's fantastic yeah I
think you got appreciation of my career
and I got an appreciation of yours
that's for sure
I wasn't even supposed to be on the show
actually when we started I was just
going to be on an episode already
let's do it then we had such a rapport
me and my dad it's already lubricated
I figured that I could actually help him
thanks to that whole veterinary services
this is Charles we've captured the many
changes of Charles wardrobe and
otherwise
[Music]
God he looks like he's got tumors
this is what I see whenever I go to the
mirror and take off my clothes
[Music]
his Superman costume was a little bit
too refilling please oh I always
remember that
[Music]
[Laughter]
in the early Seasons Charles might have
looked a bit out of his element are you
going to catch him oh
he wanted to warm up yes I'm going to
warm up everybody and you too if nothing
else this is Charles my son
he is a good chaser he gets run over
there for some water
here give me water hurry up
come on Charles move it come on
he quickly became an essential part of
the team
I hear your instruments channels you
have done this before with me okay what
do you see here is a youth of prolapse
please find me a little bit
she's pushing you want me to lift her
yeah
just the back feet is okay yes it's
going all right
well this is the first time we did it
this way and it worked look at that yeah
next time this is what I'm doing
now that's the way we always do it
thank goodness Charles was here big
strong guy lifting up the hind legs
works good that way okay let's go at the
end of the day I could be anywhere right
now and I'm here because for this for
riding in the car with my dad just
spending time with him
thank you
I go from being younger and and doing
dumb things to being your own person but
I I wouldn't change anything I I loved
the experience
hi Charles thank you my best friend Beth
to be my wife I Beth take you Charles to
be my husband Mr Mrs Charles Paul
it's an incredible moment smile
first comes love then comes marriage
then comes I'm in a hurry
hey guys hi hello hello it's coming
quick I'll let you know it shouldn't be
that long when the doctor's just
sticking with her and he seems to think
the next thing is push
there's an hour and a half I looked at
the clock
okay grandparents
we have a little baby girl named Abigail
Pole
[Laughter]
[Music]
fabulous I think that's the only one
word if you can say fabulous
girls and Beth didn't stop with one
foreign
this morning we were joined by my son
Silas Pohl a nine pound baby
he's a Bruiser isn't he yes
good for you fantastic to have all that
footage and all those experiences
captured it is a blessing it's gonna be
a treasure for our family for forever
forever that's right the best home
movies in the world right that's exactly
right yes
these home movies have captured a lot of
life and a lot of cats and dogs
okay Jamie break the kids in oh there
they go
Okay who wants to go first
oh
my goodness come here bud okay
[Music]
you're fluffy you're cute
puppy you just have to be held don't you
okay all done
[Music]
mine seem to be the most resilient
okay everything looks okay really
so he gets run over and the only thing
wrong with him is ear mites
[Music]
it's unbelievable how tough these
animals are canines can't stop getting
into trouble
oh my goodness we have too many
porcupines around this area that they
can get into did he get into something
that you think
um I think he might have eaten a dish
rag
you think the dogs would learn but no he
eats rocks rocks these pups often get
into trouble all on their own I'm
I have never pulled a piece of grass out
this big from a dog's nose
sometimes trouble finds them
top then
Chris brings his dog Rocco and gummy
he's bleeding Chris thinks he's been
shot they shot him right here
it goes in here you can see the the
bones and stuff out of the Rope of his
mouth
let's get him on inside yeah come on
Rocco yeah everybody he is weak dad's
got you lacking blood and needs some
help if you look at his lower jaw and I
think the bullet's still in there it may
be I think I think there's still a
bullet in there
I'm trying to dig it out right now
lost a lot of blood he's probably got an
infection setting in he's in kind of a
shocking State yeah we need to start him
on fluids to at least get his blood
pressure back up and then reassess him
hang in there buddy
okay
I really really don't want to have to
call home and tell my family that we've
got to put him down
you know I'm scared
you know I mean I love him
the big thing is I want to make sure the
bullet's not still in there that he's
fixable
I'm just going to probe around and see
if I can do anything without actually
having to cut him
to find a hard spot near the cheek jaw
area let's shop going in it and I'm just
going to try to see if I can figure out
what it is
see it's trying to come out now that's
strange you can find a bullet underneath
the skin that hardly ever happens
[Music]
I'm feeling good about Rocco we've got
the bullet out hopefully that'll make
the bleeding stop and the irritation
stop come on buddy
I got that out of his cheek
oh man glad you got it out you know I'm
very happy
very happy good boy oh I'm such a good
boy Rocco's heading home with the
souvenir one of many that have been
collected at all Veterinary Services
over the years oh boy
you're souvenirs now watch oh my gosh
you can take it home if you want to eat
it I do not want to eat it this protein
my dad has a lot of interesting
collections of different weird Oddities
that he's seen he puts them in jars with
formaldehyde
hey don't lose your balls
[Music]
see that so she cannot chew good because
those tops see they how do you make a
hole right there from the other teeth
yeah oh man this has to be cut off
I'm glad you're not my test
you want these
um
sure
what's two figure to bring me 50 bucks a
tooth all right that went better than I
thought
I look at Chloe I'm concerned because
the rock is lodged in the small
intestine
she ate a big old stone it was like that
big
oh there you are hello baby girl
so this is your Million Dollar Ride man
the rock is definitely gonna go home
with me it's a souvenir
[Music]
there's a lot of tissue hanging there
maybe another calf okay
you know what this is
what they call a flies spanga it's a
German name for meat pillar
this was the pillar in the vagina
because as an embryo gets developed in
two halves give it to you dead
so it's a big fat bubble it's bigger
than a fatty tumor fatty tumors are just
plain fat this has some other tissue in
it I can't remember see this one looked
like a breast implant
you know it's terrible for her running
through the yard
it was so easy to remove once you cut
through the skin it just kind of peeled
right out it looks like a silicone
implant
what like a b cup and C cup
foreign
can I just take it with my hands I'll
take with my hands I don't care oh that
feels weird
cool
I noticed in a pie dish there was a
weird furry ball that looked kind of out
of place oh there's a Teratoma yeah
that's the one I like
[Music]
it was weird so what is this thing this
is my Toyota Tomah
that had pulled out of cacao last night
it was oh no
but teratoma is you know some cells that
got loose from the fetus way in the
beginning but too late to make a twin
so what is this that is little piece of
bone
sounds like a Halloween movie
yes I collect a lot of things it started
when I was in college and from there on
it's just for bad to worse if you
retired from this you said you would
open up a junk store called the trash or
treasure yes let's do it let's do it
the very best Treasures
come in the form of family pets oh
and for the polls more really is merrier
that's about time their pets range from
cats and dogs to horses and goats and
even emus hey hi Brittany they're
fantastic they're funny birds they're
like little Velociraptors in there
and we could never forget Tater the
insta-famous clinic cat with more than
50 000 followers
it's a nice cat that's my cat
Tater belongs to the clinic no taters
taters cat Tater is everybody's cat it
doesn't make any difference who comes
into the clinic they can pick them up
they can pet him he is a people cat
true loves are their Great Danes
I think we probably have had what 16
Great Danes something like that since
we've been married
it's like once you go great dane you'll
never go back I think I'm gonna name her
Athena the smartest dog he ever owned
yeah probably smarter than I am I'll
never have another dog like her she
loves the kids she loves my wife she's
really grown as I've grown
over 10 years of filming we've seen some
of these beloved pets grow into old age
Freya is the old girl and her and I you
know have a special bond
the polls have allowed the film crew in
to witness even the toughest moments
my dad has always put down his own dogs
it's actually something I think that's
really important to him
[Music]
I'm not thinking about myself in a case
like this I'm thinking about my dog
and I wanted to go as easy as possible
[Music]
there you go see it
oh that's it no more pain
too bad they don't live forever
at a certain point in time
an animal says to you enough I've had
enough of her life and then to let him
go yeah it's very hard on humans
but it's sometimes the best for animals
all right come on everybody out
but I tell my clients when we have to
put a dog down you'll never get the same
dog but it doesn't mean that you cannot
love another dog just as much
you don't know how to shake do you oh
you want to know you know how to play
dead yes you do
the Saint Bernard came to the dog pound
and then came to our Clinic
I looked in his eyes and really wanted
to adopt him and keep him
he had a good boy yes you are killing is
living a very good life he's very badly
at least he got a lot of love yeah a lot
of dogs a lot of animals a lot of love
Scout you'd think Dr Paul was seen it
all
there's two and they are actually mating
but every day offers the chance of a
surprise never seen a false pregnancy in
Iraq me neither
it's always interesting to see things
for the first time oh shoulder blade
broke sometimes that makes us like call
everyone in come look at this see what
we have we may have to just remove it
okay sort of do a con Fab together and
hash it out and come up with a game plan
I'll be dang that's the that that's
another first for me really I guess Dr
Pope hasn't quite seen everything yet
Barbara's bringing an emu in it's a
chick yet and she thinks it has a broken
leg
turn backwards
that was a sweet little thing makes you
want to get a emu baby doesn't it yeah
they're cute
I don't know how this happened this one
got broke
I just feel super helpless I mean she's
her
[Music]
she definitely was a broken leg
let's see what we can do
they go
I've never done this on an emu before
and I hope it works you're the only
person I knew that could do this you
have to immobilize The Joint above and
below a fracture you taped it around it
right I think so like a chicken when the
fracture is lined up properly pull the
leg lift it up a little bit tape it to
the body
in seconds he fixed her
okay she stopped crying there's no more
like pain put it back in because she
can't walk
see what happens in a few days the best
really the best that is not one day
they're just the same as the day before
and it'll be different again tomorrow
and I think this is why I love my work
too because this is what I thrive on
top then
what in the world is that yeah this is
weird you know he can stick his tongue
so far out of the side of his mouth he
can nearly lick his ear
in 40 years I've never seen a dog mouth
on the calf it should be a down to here
right yes she's out in her Huts there's
you know food all over everything yeah
that's why our coat's kind of dirty yeah
that is weird
[Music]
how do we fix that I don't know if we
suture it
you think it might work I don't know
let's try it we got nothing to lose
so see right here
[Music]
I think the one thing that makes my dad
an incredible veterinarian is that he's
willing to do things he's never done
before Charles
he's like no I'm going to use my 40
years of experience come up with a
solution that works for the farmer and
the animal if you don't try it you'll
never be able to say hey it worked it
worked yeah that should heal up good
here she comes to see you
man that is that is just perfect isn't
it good she didn't rip it out no but
she's eating good yeah well that's the
first I've never seen a dog mouth in the
in a cow so
we tried to make a cow mouth out of it
and I think we succeeded
like I said if you don't try you'll
never know if it works hello I don't
want you doing nothing out there to make
me sick today
time whether he's done it once hey or a
thousand times me again Dr Paul's
clients have full trust in it the great
Baldwin showed up today
Eddie ah how the heck are you Ed and I
always have fun you're looking good as
usual it's just you don't change marches
nope a bald head never changed us
okay let me have this and I'm going home
take a shower
we've got the wisdom for many years of
doing it long arms to get in there and
do the stuff he's married to his work
and he's really good at it sorry Diane
huh I'll be darned no that's why you
better go to the vet that's why we bring
them to you
thanks God for Dr Pol
y I didn't
now we do the dance of Joy
oh pepper Merry Christmas
Charlie
sorry sorry hi buddy how are you he
tells Charlie the mini horse story to
everybody yes basically I saved his life
Charlie loves coming here because he
loves Doc and I think he's Doc's
favorite mini give him a big smile Kylie
everybody at the clinic there has been
so good to us over the years it means an
awful lot to us I've been a client of Dr
pose for 28 years yeah he has Conjuring
emergencies he's come in bad weather I
remember when I was little he used to
have an old station wagon
all right like he always drives 150 mile
an hour
don't tell everybody he's always treated
us the best and he treats you like
family I don't think I could do without
Dr Paul Dr Paul has never done us wrong
ever we appreciate all that he has done
for us yeah we got all together Phil
congratulations Dr polt congratulations
congratulations congratulations I hear
it's 200 200 episodes yay yeah
you know they say they're thankful but
when you actually hear and see it in
front of you that that touches my heart
yeah it does
you do a good job you bring the animal
back to health for the owner they are
thankful and they are happy holy Moses
knock it off that's not called for
these animals have a funny way of
showing their appreciation
okay
oh where did you get Germany I love die
oh I got banged in the head I got kicked
I've gotten kicked yes I had a horse
fall on top of me and and fell on this
back pulling a calf
I'm fine bye
I'm pretty worried you're gonna be just
like real animals dying we mask our pain
right Donald Trump Emily
what happened a big Friesian Stallion
the upper leg moved and just crazed my
face
you work with animals you better watch
out you get hurt
man Allah how did you get underneath
that quiet and when dark pole takes a
hit you're sure to hear man alive man
I'll lie
demonie Charisma that's four-wheel drive
oh gee money come Christmas man holy
Moses holy Moses hi big guy how are you
holy nauseous behave yourself yep hey
behave yourself
Jeepers well there it is lots of it
Dr Paul's work isn't only dangerous it
can also be just plain gross okay if it
disappeared Charles make sure that you
grab me by the boots before I disappear
[Music]
but you've been cleaning chimney
chimney squirter oh disgusting yeah
oh for pizza
not only my boot
oh man
[Music]
the nicest thing is that we do not have
smelly fish I don't think it would be
popular if they could smell but we smell
sometimes what do you think no I don't
think so
your boots full of poop yeah
oh I think I got a whiff of it over here
I have like an acidic
rotten smell
you'll be especially thankful
smell-o-vision doesn't exist for this
next kiss
top then
Kristen is putting on her horse in he
has been tearing on one side of his face
his breath doesn't Rancid
holy cow look at the person running out
and what happened here I don't know what
it is well take a look how swollen this
is here yeah oh
poor Buck there's an abscess in his bone
and that's why it stinks like that he's
got it on a bowl so it went all the way
up here oh is it gonna be okay I don't
know
see how big that socket is there and
that pushes on the eye the eye is
secondary to this there's a soft spot in
the bone that means that there is an
infection in the sinus
this is the tranquilization
the best way to do is just open it up
I'm gonna be stinky
look at that
very nice ooh there Perfect come on I'm
good now now we have a big opening
you're all right
it smells like
rotted meat that's sat in a fridge from
years
[Laughter]
it's so good to see the bus coming out
because that's the relief yeah
does peroxide yes flush it
gosh
don't get it all you got along with your
boots
I'm okay with that
for another at least smell doesn't
bother me push it in and I'm going to
put my finger that has never been a case
where I said oh my gosh I gotta puke
okay one more time and we have had some
very bad smells and then you always come
home and say here smell
yes oh we got it
look at this
he's pouring out of his nose
oh okay
I can taste it that's bad for some
reason other people and first don't get
along
I think you should do a segment called
top 10 client reactions yes
oh we'll keep it to the top five ew I'll
make some puke right now
thank you
ah
yummy
that was terrible
oh that stinks
I've dealt with it before but that was
just raunchy holy
no holy mayonnaise
it's a good thing I don't like
absolutely
[Laughter]
pus doesn't bother me but uh the maggots
that's what I can't stand when I walk in
and they're working on maggots I just
keep right on walking
just your typical poop stuff
luckily the Vets have built-in backup
what the heck is that stupid smile for
the crew I'm here to Save the Day
filming The Incredible Dr pole can get a
little messy
[Music]
what's up
and sometimes the Vets need an extra set
of hands come on guys come on Mike
it's a Wrangler
roll here we go oh
[Music]
you know hand a newborn go to anyone
she needs to get up sure glad the crew
is still here there's no way I could
have gotten there
you're good she's got some air in there
there was some challenge in keeping the
crew safe though all in the beginning oh
hey Mark you're still walking
I actually got hit by a cow at one point
so I don't like to talk about that
Dr Paul loves to make fun of me for that
one they learned over 10 years they're a
lot better now oh heck yes despite the
hazards the crew keeps coming back I've
been on it since day one so that's a
little over 10 years since the second
season nine years since 2012 season two
and that's the nice thing about it that
you know the same people coming back and
they are doing a fantastic job to be
honest with you because they have grown
up with us in 10 years you grow up even
on yet is old you still grow up my
favorite part of the show is the added
family I feel like the film crew is part
of the family
and it's that bonding experience it goes
on behind the scenes that really is the
secret sauce to our show
I would say that the crew and the uh and
the staff and Dr polar have become
extended family it's a rare thing in
this industry so that's why I keep
coming back what keeps me here is Dr
Paul and the crew
for me is I love taking stills of the
crew
it's really hard to say
to be able to get on a show that has a
good crew
that has a good cast
[Music]
it's the reason why you stay
you can't ask for anything else really
thanks man
all right there
we've got to take about four bars of
this thing out
since season two the same composers have
been creating the perfect tunes and the
same narrator that's me has been talking
you through this Wild Ride congrats Dr
pole on 200 episodes I'm so proud to
work on this show you changed my life
congratulations Dr Pohl on 200 episodes
we're so happy to be part of what you do
foreign
thanks to the team behind the scenes
we've captured the polls sporting the
finest fashions
it's Halloween I'm going as a sexy
caveman obviously
[Music]
you might want to change the way your
kilt is it's on backwards well that is
embarrassing it's going about keep going
around boom
that's it I look mantastic
[Music]
I'm dressed up as a princess and I feel
like a princess in my long flowing gown
Charles wants me to be a monk I don't
want any confessions from you guys
good morning where are my other things
[Laughter]
once in a while we let our hair down
good morning hello Dr Paul how are you
wonderful lo and behold when I walk into
the clinic I Meet myself
you stole my shirt
there's no greater fashion statement
than
this
I'm gonna strip first
of the things that I hear is man I love
it when you take your shirt off
that doesn't bother me to have
everybody's talking about him going
shirtless but one of the some woman came
up and said oh Dr Paul I love you so
much you're in my bedroom every night
and I thought what
it's nice doc always pulls out his
signature move when delivering calves do
you remember the one in the barn with
100 degrees outside the sweat was in my
boots
top then
[Music]
it's a hundred degrees out today it's
incredibly hot
oh boy is she hot inside okay Charles I
need all the change geez that's hot in
that wall it was 98 degrees outside 140
in the cow
I couldn't cool off
to the uterus inside is twisted around
the curve is Upside Down Chris this must
be a ball cat
stubbornness
okay here
just pull and let go hang on for a
second
pull
pull
he trained you well right that's right
although I've learned over the years you
don't lean back too far into it unless
you want to end up on your back side
man I like that thing I swear down
okay man I started knew the cat was
alive Paul Charles
Temple Maybe
but I wasn't promising any results not
until the cab comes out breathing
Charles fall on the legs all right
time is definitely ticking this cow is
under a lot of stress it's a hundred
degrees out oh no let go
I will never forget that that was
probably the hardest cabin
suck it up
gigantic cap oh
my gosh it's a live one
isn't that amazing though
it's amazing I got to suck around
without me all right it is one thing
I'll give Dr po a lot of credit he don't
give up easy okay when the Cav comes out
alive it's all worthwhile got pretty
good at it over the last 10 years I
would say so
he even lets me run the the cat puller
now yes
The Incredible Dr Paul airs around the
world
[Music]
oh that was just recently too
in 188 countries and 34 languages
no matter where you live you can catch
Dr Cole in action is
[Laughter]
that's an old one yeah so are you
you're wherever we go now we can
recognize we came to Ecuador and this
young girl comes running up to me and in
perfect thing it's just Dr Paul Diane
what are you doing here we're on
vacation
all those ladies were oh that Dr Paul
it's Dr Paul's home country of the
Netherlands where the red carpet really
rolls out
he's more famous than the Netherlands
than he is here he's like he's like the
Justin Bieber
I was born about a mile and a half from
here locally I'm a hero I don't know why
because I just do my job to commemorate
your visit we have put together a
beautiful piece of art
[Music]
come here
foreign
[Music]
oh my gosh I want to take it home
[Music]
it's still there I know yeah this is
incredible
people still are thinking that I'm a
Dutchman and are proud of me and that
makes me feel very humble but I'm still
only a veterinarian that does his job we
don't consider ourselves celebrities no
we're just regular people
I guess waiting through poop will keep
you humble
Global record
your Pole's biggest fan is right here at
home you're crazy kid
now that my daughter's two years old
she's discovered oppa on television what
you watching Abigail
hello Abigail hi Abigail how are you
what do you want to watch oh crap let's
[Music]
you think you're gonna watch Oppa today
no you want to go watch Oma too
yes
we are at the Isabel County Fair and I'm
showing my Dairy feeder
my cow's name is Burrito Shawn is my
rabbit Nemo marshmallow Phoenix and I am
showing my rabbit snowball
Abigail is for sure going to be a 4-H
Kidder Abigail loves taking care of
animals
my dad takes it upon himself to be a pro
bono Fair bet these are good those are
fine too much grain
yeah he's pretty good with animals
Fair animals can have problems that
start way before the fair
[Music]
buddy is a 4-H calf
he was bloated yesterday when I went out
to feed him
so I told my parents I'm not going to
school I'm taking them to the vet
hello hi what is this the fair calf yeah
it's my fair steer
oh boy yeah
we really should put a throw card in the
side
[Music]
almost
there we go
that looks good
a week 10 days for are you driving this
whole big great by yourself I drive this
every day
this is mine how old are you I'm 16.
those are Farm Growers
[Music]
I'm really happy to have taken second
[Music]
without doctor I don't know if he would
have made it to today that's my boy oh
any more open where that came from
helping kids like Katie and one day
Abigail means a lot to Doc you know that
it's very important for me the kids grow
up with animals and to see these kids
doing a good job working hard that is
really rewarding hardly more than a kid
when she started hello hello Dr Brenda
has been with the clinic for nearly 30
years
[Music]
when she first came she was fresh out of
college
I saw this farm girl coming out of the
car and said yes Brandon is a good asset
to this practice and I'm happy to have
her
Dr Brenda if you've been working with
you for 10 years 200 episodes did you
expect
no
no no
more than I ever expected let alone
almost 12 Seasons I still remember your
interview dinner oh yeah I do too that's
why I knew because we've been all day
out running around looking at things
he'd been dragging me all over tell me
stories he told me so many stories the
first day my head almost explored and at
the end of the day he's like well come
home for dinner and so here we are we
all sit down at the dinner table and
it's like I could just put different
faces on the bodies and they were my
whole family it was cool to know that I
think it was very strange but it worked
out so yeah we've been here a long time
Dr Brenda and Dr Paul work well together
got a minute because they can bounce the
ideas off of each other why is that all
so thick I don't like her body
temperature either especially as hot as
it is they kind of seem to know what the
other one needs when the other one needs
it I like we're going back to pole it
can be fun it can be exciting yeah
that's an apple that's what I thought
too when I was feeling it
when an animal has too many legs six to
be exact
it takes multiple hands to figure it out
top then
let's go back go the building today is
going to be on our homes and operation
it's unique and unusual and we probably
won't ever see another one of these in
our practice lives
okay
two heads are always smarter than in one
I will start on this Sideburn and pull
everything off
[Music]
stay away from that nurse there
my concern is that we don't cause injury
to the calf
and make her unable to to survive the
surgery okay we're we're still connected
somewhere yeah let me have it
right there yeah
almost out
Dr Pohl Dr Brenda and Dr Emily worked
together on a rare surgery there it is
cut it good
so did you just finish and be like okay
Dr Brenda you uh Stitch It Up Scott
got prognosis for this calf now that
she's had surgery is very good
see do you see Dr Paul in that picture
no stuck in front of us
[Music]
as soon as our stitches are out you
probably won't be able to even pick her
out of the crowd
[Music]
hey this is rank in the top 10 what do
you think of this one nah
this is everyday work
I think it's pretty cool I think it
would be kind of cool if Brenda would
bring out her special earrings and wear
those once at all I don't know if that's
gonna happen though
come on lady smooth
the first year I worked here I had to
work really hard to run the respect of
the clients easy babe you're all right
there were several of them that were
very leery about the fact that I'm a
girl she is not pregnant pregnant there
you go
so you ever get them uh
I have to get out them cat testicles
anymore lately here now my earrings that
I haven't are made out of cat testicles
now in that struggling first year I was
talking to my classmate and complaining
because the farmers really thought I
should be a man and apparently I should
have testicles so she tried to help me
out she made a custom pair of earrings
for me from cat testicles so that I
would have testicles
you still got them you still have them
thankfully I'm pretty secure without the
Tesco so yeah
hopefully I've smoothed it out with the
clients a long time ago like girls are
okay go on yeah now it's like oh oh
you're a man yeah yeah yeah
thinking back we feel uh richly West
that doc Brenda has stuck her own uh
over the years it's been it's been it's
been quite the journey
there's not a lot of veterinarians that
work on reindeer
Dr Brenda is the one that we count on
good morning Dave how are you not too
good actually this doesn't look good
she can't walk she likes she's drunk
okay
[Music]
you know what she got the shakes bed
yeah I'll go over here come on
come on yeah you're not in good shape
I think Angel has contracted meningeal
worm
the meningo worm is a parasite they tend
to migrate through all the tissues
including the spinal column and that's
why we get some of these very weird
neurological symptoms in the animals all
right this is what I think we should do
with her give her some dexamethasone
that may help reduce some of the
inflammation I'm going to put her on an
antibiotic also just from a respiratory
rate
there you go all right
after Dr Brenda left after treating her
I had a meeting with all the Santa
Clauses and we all said a little prayer
that angel is going to come out of this
all right by golly she did
Santa seems to be pretty pleased I stay
on the nice list thankfully so 10 years
has been long and short
um now I'm gonna cry you shouldn't ask
me this question
yeah
it's been interesting and challenging
and cool and weird and scary and just
about every every adjective you can use
at some point during the whole thing I
gotta get back to work so you guys have
a good day all right thank you
Dr Brenda is due back at the clinic
but these animals want to be anywhere
but
oh come on
foreign
Mr Happy
oh
come here
[Applause]
[Music]
there you go no you don't
um
stay in there Chase it back
[Applause]
[Music]
are you kidding me
Simba I gotta jump this
Kitty he's right there
French
all I'm thinking is oh my God no no
they think he peed on me a little
slam the gate on him oh the other one's
going
[Music]
oh shoot
I tell you those things can run
the five minute mile is nothing for him
animals May flee at the site of Dr Pol
welcome to the Madhouse
young veterinarians are racing to work
with him
what's the uh the Newbie that is Dr
Emily that's Dale he's the funny guy I
like getting on the farm to play with
cows a visit to Clay knot Dairy is a
rite of passage for every new vet that's
Lisa hi I'm Dr Nicole
what you got open nothing on the right
maybe a small follicles on the left
I don't know for sure you'll learn this
kind of does feel like a test
I think this one's open
we'll have them check okay
perfect but once he agreed with my first
call I said okay I got this
yeah yeah
I'm gonna like come here
[Music]
before long the new vets are teaching
each other the podcast before
no no you take this one gently pull when
she pushes
I graduated 50 years ago things have
changed quite a bit so when you get a
new bedding there are always new things
any change for the better is something
that I accept
200th episode shout out shout out
congratulations Dr Pol on 200 episodes
that's pretty crazy what a remarkable
accomplishment I've been working with Dr
Poole for about four years now and every
day has been great working with Dr Pol
is is always an adventure
almost as fun as getting to hang out
with tater
so here's to 200 more
the new vets have made their mark
handling even some of the most
surprising cases
top 10.
today we're coming out to see a horse
that was oops last night and he ended up
taking a topple into the ditch and
landed on some kind of metal hole
come here
when Blazer breathes you can see some
air coming in and out of his chest
cavity
that's one of the cold days cold snap
how long it might sting a little bit so
that will give some pain relief so that
way he doesn't feel this there's a hole
my fingers can't even reach that deep so
that means it's a pretty deep wound
what I can do is try to suture it back
up
and hopefully that'll stop the air from
escaping
I don't think I'm going to be able to
get all of this noise to stop but at
least a good majority of it good boy
you're such a good horsey
so we'll go ahead and give him pain
medication and then strong antibiotics
for quite a few weeks
[Music]
Blazer is doing really well he made a
full recovery
and I'm glad that I got to give him that
second chance the animals
that's why I love them
you know what these are what these are
the blood vessels when it comes to
humans Dr Pol never misses a chance to
share his Country Vet wisdom the main
thing is if there's green stuff that
means the surface is opening up and that
the placentas letting go yes listen to
that recipe sound
who better to learn from the doctor poll
it's a lot better than staying in school
I want the owner of the pet makes no
difference Lodge at our small animals
what my diagnosis is how I treat it why
I treat it this way and what the outcome
will be and you hope they learn and I
hope they learn hi kids
how is everybody today and there's no
one he'd rather teach than the Next
Generation
we love our donkeys whose horse is it
all of ours all of ours
this is how you do it now when the Hawks
are out that means the pelvis
is in the cow
you gotta go pretty fast otherwise they
drown he's very enthusiastic about it
love showing us how to do this so that
we can learn
he's alive I see how she gets in there
right away yeah that's a kit for you
that's what the farm does for the kid oh
yeah you're gonna get it
people that love to learn I love to
teach and kids like this they are so
eager to learn you're all set thank you
all right thank you and why not teach
them
I'm not going to be here forever
Maybe
[Laughter]
a farm is a good place for kids to grow
up
they get exposed they have they learn
the work ethic but at the same time they
learn to work with animals
[Music]
come out to join them we got some good
helpers I love working on the farm with
my dad pregnant 40
Telly she's my little bookkeeper she
loves to help she is open I had to write
down the colors
um if they were bred if they were open
or if they were pregnant she's open
pregnant 95.
pregnant
you're gonna grow up and help out on the
farm you're gonna take over one day is
that the goal I think that would be kind
of cool to take over the farm
foreign
how many cars did we do 41 that many
and you kept up with me you're good
I want to congratulate Dr Paul on his
200th episode I will always have the
memories of Dr Paul flying in our
driveway in his Jeep just fine
everywhere but I knew Dr Paul was here
to save the day
10 years wow you go from a little kid
yeah a college student oh
[Music]
kids grow up vets come and go
change seems to be a constant for pole
Veterinary Services
[Music]
morning guys good morning what you got
hello one of the biggest changes in
recent years has been the arrival of the
covid-19 pandemic all right we'll be
back okay thank you since the pandemic
started we have been very careful to
follow all the rules and regulations
we do have to do the precautions of red
on the mask how much does he weigh he's
like 35 pounds and not to be in close
contact to people
if no improvement getting worse let me
know the pandemic hasn't only changed
Clinic protocols but also how the show
is made we had to figure out how to
shoot the show in a completely different
way we had to go to remote cameras the
exam rooms are the main Hub of where we
shoot this show so as you can see we
have three PTZ cameras those are remote
operated cameras we have the camera that
can capture the pet angle hello camera
we have the camera that can capture the
client hello camera and then we have the
camera that can capture the veterinarian
hello camera now the show just wouldn't
be the same if my mom wasn't a big part
of it so we have two cameras that can
actually capture my mom's desk the uh
front office area but also our little
Hub of the office which is the kitchen
okay who's next
it turned to be a blessing in disguise
where sometimes the challenges that you
have end up showing you a different way
to do something huh
okay
makes no difference what is going on
pandemic and opandamic animals need
attention I'll take him inside and take
a look at him yeah oh baby not even a
pandemic can stop a little puppy love
when everything got shut down routine
was not allowed because we couldn't do
routine things we couldn't spay and
castrate and so there was an abundance
of new kittens and puppies being born
this wasn't a planned pregnancy so the
father is a little bit larger and she's
so small
hi hello
we brought pixita to see if she was
gonna be able okay to have the puppies
naturally right now she's in labor she's
been in labor since early this morning
and there's no puppies yet
well she's not progressed at all as soon
as puppies and um he's been in labor you
know six hours this morning yes
so most like a c-section probably
okay
when a dog cannot have its puppies for
one reason or another you know don't
wait too long and she's ready to go but
her birth canal is very tiny so just go
ahead and do a C-section so you get live
pops
[Music]
oh my goodness
[Music]
I'm so excited kids and puppies we were
expecting three but there was a little
surprise puppy in there so everybody's
doing good and we're super happy wow
oh
another day like yesterday I'm calling
it quits I retire
I'm right behind you yeah right
this little ditty about Jan and Diane
has been going strong for more than 50
years
we met in 61 the very first time when I
came off the plane in Detroit and I saw
her with her mom and dad and I thought
my gosh what a long-legged girl
you enroll me in the freaking AARP
thinking maybe
it's a hearing aid that was like eight
years ago
for 200 episodes we've been documenting
every kiss and special moment of their
endearing Love Story love ya
and tomorrow we work again
[Music]
I love you
and I promise that I'll love you as long
as you both shall live
and now you want me to better that
50 years ago we said I do 50 years ups
and downs but always good and always
together
the next 50 years is going to be a
little bit harder but I'm going for it
how about you
thank you
[Applause]
change the bed
ah here it comes Diane always the one
that I go on a one horse open sleigh in
the snow and she's going to get it this
year oh
happy birthday
[Music]
[Laughter]
aren't you I started crying actually I
was so happy to see her out there and
she looked so pretty
and the sleigh looks so beautiful
let's see if you can make it
that made me feel very nice because this
was always one of her dreams
cool
I'm glad we have it in the movie because
we can enjoy it again I think I grinned
from ear to ear the whole time I just
kept thinking I can't believe I'm doing
this
[Music]
yeah
that was definitely my number one
I can't believe that
peas and carrots those two
call your
storybook romance storybook heck no
um actually I never really thought about
it as being anything unusual but we've
had a very good romance and we've had a
very good marriage I think Beth and I
would be lucky to have what they have
and that's my hope and dream for our
marriage you know you could do worse
than 50 years together
[Laughter]
dry your eyes we're not done yet it's
time for the final three incredible
cases
top then
[Music]
come on
good girl I just discovered this morning
when I was putting her out that there's
blood in her stall
there was blood coming out of her mouth
as well
[Music]
oh yeah the teeth yeah
the whole jaw was hanging down yeah
two teeth are hanging down there's a
piece of joy in there dang it damn it
bust the teeth right out of the bottom
jaw those little mini horses they're too
strong and they never listen I'm gonna
knock her out
Bingo good
okay water this case is pretty extreme
the bottom part of the jaw has
completely detached
holy cow
this is the tooth and I think the roots
are still there these are baby teeth
which makes it nice these two teeth will
fall out but we have to make sure that
the socket for the new ones that are
coming in have to be straight I'm gonna
pull it together and just like that yeah
that's kind of hard because you have to
sew around the teeth yeah that's what he
wanted
that looks good
yes sir good
pretty even if anybody could do it it's
my dad and that thing healed up
completely too that's more than the
plastic surgeon
fun
Karma's doing fantastic she's eating
correctly
good girl it was a very bad injury and
usually don't have a happily ever after
after this and we have one with this one
even the horse dances that they have
coming out said it was a fantastic job
and that makes me feel so good Hey
where's the
cat with the arrow
top then
[Music]
Paul is bringing a cat in and this is
something else
[Music]
our cat came home with a crossbow arrow
stuck through its head you don't see
that every day no no wow
the neighbors shot him
it's okay doctor's gonna make it better
we're gonna give him an anesthetic
and he's my buddy he sleeps on me just
about every night and
stuff like that is uncalled for yes this
is uncalled for okay it's okay I got it
you don't shoot a bow and arrow at the
cat it's animal cruelty it's painful so
making a police report yes
it didn't do anything except just the
damage is here not even the air it
didn't hit anything vital so there's no
blood this Arrow just bounces off the
bone and keeps going so you have a hole
from one end to the other and it's just
underneath the skin
yeah there definitely is one of nine
lives right there yes
there's nothing busted in the skull or
anything
what we have to do is just clean the
wound give it antibiotics and let it
heal
[Music]
come here come on ash time to come in
as he's doing really good it's
completely healed except he has a little
scar over his eye but he's back to his
Rowdy self you know he's not just a pet
he's part of the family
it's not every day you get to see a cat
shot through the head with an arrow that
one was definitely top 10 worthy yes I
would say so too yeah and now the case
worthy of the coveted number one spot
top 10 top ten oh there's your top 10
top 10 top 10.
top 10.
step on it duka called that he has a cow
that's trying to have a cat
we're like the post office we go out
rain sleet or snow yep
I can't hear them
this is what I don't like to hear
hang on and play holy Moses
it's easy to drive because it's nice and
smooth
finally
I don't skate but I definitely know how
to drive on ice
okay let's feel
oh
yes that's a Twist and a bad twist
that is just like a bread bag that you
twist off the YouTube then fills up with
fluids and the calf doesn't get any
Oxygen that actually dies so what we're
going to do we're going to lay the cow
right down here and we roll on the cow
hey we try to get a hold of her watch it
guys
and of course she runs all over the top
of us hang on for a second she's down so
we might as well roar The Twist is that
way so she has to roll that way pull her
head over look crew openness
hang on thank goodness for all these
extra people
I was hanging on we rolled it the right
way just over the back it's out already
and the twist was out Victor was
beautiful yeah I was going to pull it
right here
and she goes she strains oh come on and
I tell you that uterine fluid came right
at me it went right underneath my nose
over my shoulders and down my front I
was so good
when all the fluid comes out then
finally the cap is reachable
my shirt comes off and I go for it I'm
on the book this camp now
there was a lot of fluid in the uterus
some of that fluid probably went also in
the lungs of the calf okay
for both of everybody
[Music]
there's the head you can breathe yeah
now you're talking
[Music]
now we have to work hard in order to
keep the calf alive
pick it up by the height legs and
Charles you help them The Swinging is
where the fluid swings out
put your fingers in the mouth you stick
the fingers up the nose come on anything
to irritate to make that calf mad come
on so it starts breathe yeah it's
breathing yeah that's one
and that's two very few of those you can
bring back there you go three
but this one we did
yep look at
look at it we were just in time to be
honest with and with everybody's effort
we got it breathing that's what I want
it's fun isn't it yeah that was fun yes
it's been a good ride it's been a fun 10
years the happiness we bring two people
with this show is unbelievable the
entire 10 years has been a favorite
moment I think it's all been fantastic
yes let's see you all again
are you ready to do 200 more I am but
let's ask the boss I'm up for we better
get on the middle yeah okay let's go bye
Diane man I'm getting stiff
a lot safer than 10 years ago I want why
cut
[Music]
[Music]